Warren Nord is Luther's attorney we're
happy to have him on dime-store thanks
so much for coming on so your client is
in jail right now that's correct that he
remanded her to the sheriff's department
while we were in the court yesterday so
she was such a threat to the city of
Dallas that there couldn't be a period
between conviction sentencing she just
had to go right to jail that's correct
because she committed the actual crime
of heresy against the city of Dallas and
it's oligarchy that decided that real
criminals could go to jail but people
who were heretics are people who are
real criminals can be led out but the
heretics could go to jail and and he
demanded that she admits she was being
selfish and being offensive and
apologized to everybody
he actually said I want you to apologize
for being selfish and so of course she
wasn't being selfish she's just trying
to earn a dollar like all of these
people that are hurting
so all these salons all these people
they only get paid when they do haircuts
they're contractors there's no
government funds for those guys even
Shelley who's a salon owner could have
access to some funds which she received
recently but but her but her business
family have no funds and she don't
receive that recently and so this
buffoon hacked judge really the most
entitled person in Dallas decide she
must be a prison let me ask you a
question since you were an attorney but
she violated the law but my
understanding is laws are passed by
legislatures by elected officials right
this so-called law is just to decree I
don't understand how that's a law and
how you can go to jail because you
violated it well we have we have a law
that says that you can be enjoined from
breaking an ordinance and so then we
have a mayor that says I'm going to
announce the fourth amended emergency
regulations and they have the force and
effect of laws they're not laws but
that's what they are so what we've seen
Tucker in is that this this emergency
has exposed all the tiny tyrants for who
they are they've got this glimpse of
power and man they're gonna show
everybody exactly what to do and so if
you don't follow exactly what they do
then here's a man who says and we
take we can say that we understand the
virus is serious without saying look
we're all going to be Walking Dead
zombies next month right we can do
what's reasonable and so this man
believes well it says it's an epidemic
and we have to do something
but he's effect if he believes that then
what he's doing is he's saying you get a
potential death sentence because I'm
sending you to the jail that we're
kicking her criminals out of so serious
business yeah I have a feeling if she
was here illegally from another country
their chance start let me just calculate
zero that she would be in jail right
right now so I'm just getting word that
the lieutenant governor of Texas Dan
Patrick has offered to take her place in
jail to pay her $7,000 fine do you think
that would be a sufficient burnt
offering for Moses over there on your
bench or no no no he she has to bend the
knee I mean that's that's what he wants
and in the order even in the order for
contempt that he says if you will but
express contrition and and apologize
then we could we could look at doing
this we could fix this the idea the Dan
Patrick or anybody could take the place
is not gonna be sufficient they want her
to bend the knee that nothing else will
suffice
is that allowed I mean I don't know
where now I'm not that familiar with the
Texas legal code but is there a law in
Texas that says you have to grovel
before morons who are wearing robes is
that part of the law there or is that to
something he made up from the bench I
appear before a lot of judges Tucker so
I can't say that too much but I can tell
you that there's I've never seen that
I've never seen and I've had judges that
are mad at me but I've never had a judge
say you must admit how selfish you're
being in order to grant me for me to
grant you mercy you know he didn't have
to do that he could have said look I
know you're just trying to earn a living
but I've got to enforce to law so I'm
gonna hit you with five hundred dollars
a day and let you go he could have done
that but that wasn't what he wanted he
want he wrote he wants to contrition he
wants that apology well he said he's
like a powered drunk third grade teacher
can't chew the gum unless you have
enough for everybody was that part of
his order - don't ask don't answer that
pure speculation thank you for coming on
tonight and good luck to your client
more than good luck we're rooting for
this is an awful thing that's happened
and I hope it awakens people to what's
happening in a lot
places we filed a an application for a
writ of habeas corpus a few minutes ago
and we're hoping that the Supreme Court
of Texas will take action I hope so too
great decision I thank you thank for
having us